it's v
where'd you get a gig for me you heard
right
i need a driver
and for what exactly oh you know
this and that i got a few errands to run
a couple of friends that need paying a
visit the usual
listen i'm a straight shooter so let me
cut right to the chase
i heard you're the best in town thing is
i like working with the best
and i know the best don't come cheap
i'm not gonna get into the nuts and
bolts cause
if what they say about you is true
you can handle anything so let's get
this settled
you got what it takes or are they wrong
about you
all right i'm in japan town then
by the market entrance give a few hugs
and i'll stroll up
later be
what
[Music]
[ __ ] he's butchering up
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cuz
[Music]
is
[Music]
hey you're v yes oh
[ __ ] you didn't answer my question
[Music]
uh there's uh something on your face
the grenade can i ask why you have a
juggling accident or something not
cool you ask personal questions and yet
you haven't even introduced yourself
you are v correct
yeah that's me good and let's go
we're zoo little china i have a craving
for kung pao chicken
extra spicy
[Music]
moon
doesn't bother you what a grenade
you know
i just got to be careful not to pull the
pin when i want to pick my nose
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the place wait for me here and
keep the engine running
[Music]
is
ah
what the [ __ ] was that you got grenades
up your ass too
[Music]
please
not bad right it would have been even
better if you told me what you were
planning from the get-go
it's true what they say they're good
really [ __ ] good got a stick up your
ass though
this is where we part ways good luck v
and uh relax a bit okay
[Music]
are you gonna tell me about the grenade
oh
that my brother ripped it off during a
fight
with pliers happy family
you don't know the half of it i could
have chipped another one but
i don't know i think this matches my
style more
uh-huh besides it's a real icebreaker
with the ladies
got me powder from my nose and
doesn't work not really what about my
painting
what about it here like i said before
the best don't come cheap take care v
and hey keep your nose to the ground
your executives your leaders but they
are not human
no but then what you ask
reptilians